vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos de
simplificación de expresiones
trigonométricas así que vamos a
considerar que tenemos la expresión
1 - el seno cuadrado de teta todo eso
multiplicado por digamos coseno cuadrado
de teta y entonces bien cómo puedo
simplificar esto pues ya sabemos algunas
identidades que econométricas de las
cuales quizás la más básica y la más
importante que sale directo al círculo
unitario es que el coseno al cuadrado de
un ángulo teta más el seno al cuadrado
de un ángulo teta siempre van a sumar 1
y entonces si de aquí yo restó seno
cuadra beteta de ambos lados obtengo que
el coseno cuadrado de teta va a ser
igual a uno menos el seno al cuadrado de
teta que es justo lo que tengo aquí de
hecho también tengo el coste no al
cuadrado de teta que también aparece acá
pero vamos a sustituir vamos a sustituir
por coseno cuadrado de teta simplemente
porque eso es más fácil de manejar
así que obtendría esto se convierte en
el cose no cuadra de teta x otro cose no
cuadra de teta x coseno cuadrado de teta
ahora bien cuánto vale esto pues coseno
cuadrado y teta por coser o cuadrado
teta simplemente es coser no detecta
porque se no detecta aportase no detecta
por coseno beteta que es coseno a la
cuarta
dt está muy bien todas estas cosas son
iguales aunque ya hagamos otro ejemplo
imaginemos que ahora tenemos algo así
como seno al cuadrado de t está dividido
entre digamos uno menos el seno al
cuadrado de teta que podríamos hacer con
esto pues para empezar noten que este
caso de aquí abajo uno menos el seno
cuadrado de teta acabamos de ver que es
coseno al cuadro de teta
así que esto sería igual a seno al
cuadrado de teta seno al cuadrado de t
está dividido entre el coseno al 4
dividido entre el coseno al cuadrado de
teta ahora esto sencillamente es el seno
de teta
entre el coseno de teta
y todo eso al cuadrado todo eso al
cuadrado pero cuánto vale el seno de
teta entre el coseno etc pues nosotros
ya sabemos que eso vale tangente de teta
así que tendríamos tangente al cuadrado
de teta hagamos un último ejemplo para
esta última supongamos que tengo coseno
al cuadrado de teta más digamos
1 + seno al cuadrado de teta cuánto
valdría esto pues quizás por los colores
que usted está intentado buscar una
identidad para uno más en el cuadro de
teta pero en realidad es mucho más
simple solo tenemos que ver que este
coche no cuadra beteta más este seno
cuadrado de teta silos reacomodo hilos
juntos
cuanto vale pues vale 1 así que esto
simplemente sería uno más
este otro uno así que sería uno más uno
que es dos y ya está muy fácil no